[Music]
your company your guys came up with an
app mmm
bad robot your company is bad robot you
came up with a bad robot app which is
really fun I actually used it this
morning with my son who's six and he
loves it oh it's so much fun maybe you
could describe what it's called action
movie effects it's on the iPhone and
it's it's it's an app that lets you put
for a professional like Hollywood visual
effects into clips that you shoot yes
and so and we have a new you get like
get different new effects all the time
we have new ones coming out next week
it's a it's a really fun ridiculous that
it's fun cuz I was just well you know
about to take my kid to school and I
just said you want to play with this and
I shot a little video with him and then
showed him the app and he's a boy so he
loved it just as like a missile
it's him video of him and then the
missile goes and hits him and explodes
and I've seen little girls are horrified
why would you do that so really fun it's
a really fun app and we have a couple of
cool effects there's a new one coming
out in a week or so that's sort of like
like the alien sort of chestburster one
too which is kind of what's run through
them really quickly cuz I think people
enjoy this I think the first one is I
think you can do one where you you fire
a missile is that right yeah I want to
try that right now it's just
why why are you so thrilled to see my
head blown its mob is okay and we have
another one I think this is one for the
audience this is one where a car crashes
on the audience let's see
there's a secret oh yeah there's a
secret tell us what that is
I love secret think I hate it I love
secret things where you know like sort
of Easter eggs and stuff yeah
videos this is a little thing where if
you have the app and you if you have it
and you go to the home screen you shake
it and you hit the scene select button
three times you get another secret to
the computer crash one okay if you have
crash one let's try it on and see what
happens
it sort of the alien you kind of for the
chest grocery one the new one is
available that next week this is an
alien
it's
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]